This is what I typically eat in a day as a recipe mom
and a mom nourishing herself. Preconception.
So starting off I always have three eggs,
my homemade sourdough bread with grass fed butter and pasture
a sausage. Then I was in my ovulation phase,
so afterwards I had a raw milk Yogi coffee.
Then I have my supplements called liver oil,
beef liver, and I have some bruises for foliage and all the good stuff.
Then as a morning snack, I have a protein shake,
raw milk protein shake packed with grass fed whey protein,
B pollen, all the nutrients.
For lunch I had homemade yogurt sauce,
grass fed beef, homemade tortillas,
cucumbers and tomatoes. I always like to have my herbal iced tea
with a splash of homemade lemonade
and then my rocker salad in between lunch and my afternoon snack.
Then I had a little bit of kafir kefir,
rock kefir, and then I had my afternoon snack which was raw cheese,
bee pollen, honey,
homemade sourdough crackers,
smoked oysters, cherries,
and a seaweed snack.
Then for dinner I had homemade meat sauce with raw cheese and pasta.
As a bedtime snack, I had raw milk with grass fruit,
collagen and colostrum. Then I had a B vitamin and folate
and collagen filled chocolate chip cookie.